[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ihr wünscht euch ja immer einfache Rezepte,
am besten Rezepte,
die man kurz vorbereitet und dann in den Ofen schiebt
und hat dann am Ende so ein richtig tolles Menü.
Genau das habe ich mir heute vorgenommen.
Und zwar lieben wir persönlich Ofengerichte, denn,
wenn man am Herd steht,
muss man schon immer wieder aufpassen und rühren.
Im Ofen muss man im Prinzip
nur eine Uhrzeit einstellen und fertig.
Und ich mache heute eine Süßkartoffelpfanne.
Das Ganze wird dann hier
im großen Emailleblech zubereitet.
Und es ist am Ende wirklich
was richtig schönes Ausgefallenes auch.
Also
ich habe es noch nicht selber ausprobiert.
Das war so in meinem Kopf
und jetzt habe ich es einfach mal zusammengestellt.
Hier habe ich jetzt schon mal die ersten Zutaten.
Gleich mache ich noch eine zweite Zutat,
so einen Spinat-Rahm
– Rahm vielleicht nicht, aber so einen kleinen Spinateintopf.
Und der kommt dann noch dazu.
Und ich glaube, dass alles perfekt zueinander passt.
Ich verwende dafür
vier Süßkartoffeln,
– die sind auch relativ groß –
etwas Olivenöl,
eine Knoblauchknolle,
zwei Limetten,
500 Gramm Tomaten,
– da nehme ich jetzt Cocktailtomaten in Rot und Gelb –
etwas Salz,
Pfeffer
und Senfkörner.
Die Tomaten sind aus dem Garten.
>> ELA: Mami?
>> SALLY: Ja, mein Schatz.
>> ELA: Können wir jetzt die Kekse haben?
>> SALLY: Die Kekse, die sind noch nicht fertig.
Ich gebe sie euch gleich, okay?
>> ELA: Die riechen
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: aber schon gut.
>> SALLY: Die riechen gut, gell?
Und ich kann jetzt hier schon mal
die Süßkartoffeln einfach halbieren.
>> ELA: Mami, wo sind die Kekse?
>> SALLY: Oh, die sind richtig groß und dick.
>> ELA: Was machst du?
>> SALLY: Ich mache uns Abendessen.
>> ELA: Und was ist das?
>> SALLY: Eine Süßkartoffel.
>> ELA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> ELA: Kann ich mal probieren?
>> SALLY: Probieren?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Probier mal.
>> SALLY: Aber die schmeckt gekocht besser als roh.
Und?
>> ELA: Lecker.
>> SALLY: Lecker!
>> ELA: Schneide sie bitte nicht.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und ich ritze die jetzt hier
einfach noch kreuzförmig kurz ein.
So dringt der Geschmack einfach
noch ein bisschen besser ein.
>> ELA: Mama ist das mehr als 100?
>> SALLY: Nee, das sind 50.
>> ELA: Ist 50 mehr als 100?
>> SALLY: Nein, das ist die Hälfte.
>> ELA: Von 100?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Die 100 hast du eben gemacht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich das Öl hier in die große Form.
Das ist jetzt die 36er Emailleform.
Da kommen jetzt auch die Gewürze dazu,
also Salz und Pfeffer.
Die Knoblauchknolle,
– also wundert euch jetzt nicht, dass ich eine ganze benutze –
die halbiere ich jetzt hier.
[Musik]
Jetzt kurz verrühren,
damit sich das Salz auch schön verteilen kann.
Okay.
Die Süßkartoffeln lege ich dann
mit der Schnittfläche nach unten auf.
Perfekt!
Und die Knoblauchknolle
mit der Schnittfläche auch.
Die röstet dann nämlich richtig gut.
So.
Und jetzt kann ich das Ganze
schon mal vorgaren im Backofen.
Die Tomaten brauche ich jetzt erst mal noch nicht.
Die lege ich kurz zur Seite,
die Senfkörner genauso
und auch die Limetten.
Die kommen später dazu.
Und das kommt jetzt so erst mal in den Backofen,
wird vorgegart.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal den Spinat vorbereiten.
[Musik]
Dafür nehme ich 40 Gramm Olivenöl,
zwei rote Zwiebeln,
zwei Knoblauchzehen,
50 Gramm Tomatenmark,
eine Limette,
Salz, Pfeffer, Chili und Curry
und ein Kilo Spinat.
Ich mache es mir jetzt ein bisschen einfach
und habe hier Babyspinat
bereits gewaschen und trocken geschleudert.
Wenn ihr größere Spinatblätter habt,
dann könnt ihr die noch fein schneiden,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Ich kann jetzt hier jedenfalls schon einmal
das Öl erhitzen in einem großen Topf
bei mittelhoher Hitze
und die Zwiebeln und die Knoblauchzehen
einfach nur fein schneiden.
Bei der Zwiebel am besten hier die Wurzel zusammen lassen,
das heißt, von hinten aus nach vorne schneiden.
Dann drehen.
Und dann habt ihr schöne feine Würfel.
Und sie fällt nicht auseinander.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel
direkt anbraten.
Beim Öl auch immer aufpassen,
das Öl nicht zu hoch erhitzen.
Also Olivenöl kann man schon erhitzen so bis 180°C.
Ich habe da immer so ein natives Olivenöl extra.
Aber man sollte generell bei Ölen einfach
den Rauchpunkt nicht übersteigen.
Das hier schön anbraten.
Und das geht schneller, wenn der Deckel drauf ist.
In der Zeit können sich meine Augen
von der Zwiebel etwas beruhigen.
Jedes Mal!
Ich weiß, ich muss eure Tipps ausprobieren.
Wasser im Mund,
Zunge raus,
Toastbrot essen.
Aber ich vergesse es immer.
Und dann ist es immer zu spät
und dann weine ich immer schon.
>> JOSH: Du musst alles gleichzeitig machen.
>> SALLY: Alles gleichzeitig,
Wasser mit Toastbrot im Mund
und gleichzeitig die Zunge raus
und Taucherbrille an.
Jetzt sind die Zwiebeln perfekt
und ich kann das Tomatenmark dazu geben.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen türkisch angehaucht,
muss ich sagen.
Wobei, wenn es komplett türkisch wäre,
hätte ich Butter benutzt.
Denn da ist immer so
der Start eines jeden Gerichts
Butter mit Zwiebel und Knoblauch
und dann Tomatenmark dazu.
Da ist allein schon der Geruch perfekt.
So. Kurz mit anbraten.
Und dann gebe ich den Spinat dazu.
Standardspruch:
Ich weiß, es sieht jetzt nach ziemlich viel aus,
aber es wird gleich sehr wenig.
Der fällt nämlich gleich zusammen.
Aber ich wollte halt jetzt heute
so eine richtig große Gemüsemenge machen.
Und deswegen, finde ich,
nutzen wir halt echt mal viel Spinat.
Ich gucke später mal, wie groß die Portion ist,
also für wie viele Personen.
Und ihr könnt es euch ja dann hoch- oder runterrechnen.
Ja.
Schön durchrühren.
Und wenn es nicht auf einmal reinpasst,
dann einfach kurz den Deckel drauf geben,
einkochen lassen.
Und dann gebe ich gleich den Rest dazu so nach und nach.
Und immer wieder rühren.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier direkt die Gewürze dazu geben
und auch etwas Säure, nämlich Limettensaft.
Und dann lasse ich den Spinat
einfach noch ein bisschen einkochen.
Er muss jetzt aber gar nicht komplett durch sein,
weil es zum einen Babyspinat ist
und zum anderen, finde ich, darf man
schon noch ein bisschen Biss haben.
Und das Ganze kommt ja später
sowieso noch mal in den Backofen.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier eigentlich den Herd ausschalten.
Denn im Gusseisen gart das Ganze sowieso
noch ein bisschen nach mit der Restwärme.
Und mir reicht das jetzt so auf jeden Fall schon.
Hauptsache, ein bisschen zusammenfallen lassen.
Und fertig.
Also das hat jetzt auch nicht länger gedauert
als sieben bis acht Minuten
insgesamt.
Hier noch mal abschmecken, Salz, Pfeffer, Curry.
Probiert es einfach mal.
Und dann, wie gesagt, noch ein bisschen nachziehen lassen.
Und jetzt komme ich zu meiner dritten Komponente.
Das sind die Kichererbsen.
Und ich habe jetzt hier Kichererbsen aus der Dose
und werde die jetzt aber noch schön abtrocknen.
Das Wasser habe ich übrigens aufgefangen.
Denn da sind ganz viele Proteine drin.
Da findet ihr auch bereits Rezepte auf meinem Kanal.
Denn dieses Wasser nennt man Aquafaba
und damit kann man Eischnee ersetzen.
Ihr könnt eine Mousse au Chocolat machen.
Ihr könnt ein Baiser machen.
Ich habe auch schon eine Pavlova gemacht,
also so ein Eton Mess.
Richtig gut!
Und ich brauche jetzt nur die Kichererbsen
und werde die jetzt kurz abtrocknen.
Dadurch löst sich auch ein bisschen die Haut ab.
Das ist auch sehr gut.
Oh, ich habe sie ein bisschen zerdrückt.
Nicht schlimm.
Seid vorsichtig, etwas vorsichtiger als ich.
So.
Und die werden gleich noch geröstet.
Aber die Schale, so gut es geht, entfernen.
[Musik]
Ich merke häufig, dass ich so
für eine Großfamilie koche,
also so eine richtig große Portion.
Egal.
Bisher ist das Rezept auch vegan.
Da haben auch die Veganer was davon.
Später kommt noch Käse drauf,
aber ich kann ja für die Veganer was weglegen
und dann freuen die sich auch.
Und das ist ja auch was,
das kann man auch am nächsten Tag essen.
Oder Josh nimmt es mit nach Hause.
Gell?
Lunchpaket.
>> JOSH: Wenn was übrig bleibt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und wir sind ja auch viele Leute hier.
Ich weiß so, wie sich das entwickelt hat.
Am Anfang meiner Videos immer für zwei Personen gekocht.
Dann war Samira größer, dann so für drei
und jetzt so für 20.
Und wir kochen halt immer das, worauf ich gerade Lust habe
oder worauf das Team halt so Lust hat.
Ja.
Okay, wenn es nach Marcel ginge,
dann gäbe es jeden Tag Schokoladenkuchen.
So. Da habe ich es doch.
Also es muss jetzt nicht alles weg.
Das ist okay so.
Und ich gebe jetzt hier schon mal das Olivenöl dazu,
aber die Gewürze noch nicht.
Denn ich möchte jetzt die Kichererbsen
mit den Süßkartoffeln im Ofen ein bisschen rösten.
Ich habe ja Heißluft eingestellt.
Das heißt, die kann ich jetzt auch mit reingeben.
Und die Gewürze kommen erst später rein,
denn ich möchte nicht,
dass die verbrennen und bitter werden.
Also erst mal hier nur die Kichererbsen mitrösten.
Oh, das riecht jetzt schon lecker.
Das riecht supergut.
Kurz Hände waschen und dann in den Backofen.
[Musik]
So.
Dann noch kurz nach den Kartoffeln gucken.
Ich glaube, ich hole die mal kurz raus.
Die waren jetzt insgesamt
– wartet –
insgesamt
– mh, 40 –
43 Minuten drinnen.
Und jetzt kann ich hier schon die Tomaten dazu geben.
[Musik]
Jetzt könnt ihr hier die Süßkartoffeln einmal umdrehen.
Oh!
Wunderschön!
Wunderschön sind sie!
Ich liebe einfach die Farbe und den Geschmack.
Murat kam eben schon rein und sagte:
"Oh, hier riecht es aber gut."
Ich habe ihm nur noch nicht verraten,
dass wir Süßkartoffeln machen.
Er mag die nämlich immer nicht so gerne,
aber, wenn er sie dann isst, findet er sie auch gut.
Meistens.
Also letztes Mal.
Okay, eigentlich nicht.
Aber mir ist das egal.
Ich versuche, die Optik nicht zu zerstören.
So jetzt hier schön am Rand platzieren.
Oh, ist das schön!
Oder?
Ich finde es schön.
Jetzt kommen hier die Tomaten in die Mitte,
einfach direkt zum Knoblauch.
Dann die Senfkörner.
Ein bisschen Limettenabrieb.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es später schmeckt alles,
aber ich glaube, gut.
Ich muss echt gestehen, da bin ich so ein bisschen
nach der Optik gegangen.
Also ich habe mir überlegt:
"Welches Gericht könnte hier gut ausschauen
mit den Süßkartoffeln?"
Und dann kam so
eine Komponente nach der anderen einfach dazu.
Und jetzt noch
ein bisschen Limettensaft,
so ein bisschen über die Tomaten,
aber auch über die Kartoffeln.
Und dann kommt das Gericht
wieder in den Backofen.
Die Kichererbsen können in der Zeit schön rösten.
Die Tomaten werden weich.
Die Süßkartoffeln bekommen auch noch
ein bisschen mehr Aroma.
Und später gebe ich noch den Spinat dazu.
[Musik]
Ui!
Leckerschmecker!
So sieht es jetzt aus.
Richtig gut!
Und ich werde jetzt hier die Tomaten
einfach ein bisschen zerdrücken.
Zack, zack!
Die Knoblauchknolle packe ich mal kurz zur Seite.
>> JOSH: Was? Die essen wir nicht?
>> SALLY: Doch.
Die essen wir auch, Josh.
Ich freue mich am meisten
auf die Knoblauchknolle.
Jetzt gebe ich einfach
den Spinat auch
– wieso habe ich eine kleine Gabel?
Ich habe so viel Besteck.
>> JOSH: Du kannst auch eine größere Gabel nehmen.
>> SALLY: Jetzt packe ich hier einfach den Spinat mit rein
und vermische ihn gleich mit den Tomaten.
Okay, ich habe echt gekocht für so eine Großfamilie.
[Musik]
So. Hier jetzt die Gewürze drauf.
Ich habe jetzt einfach so in jeder Komponente
Knoblauch,
in jeder Komponente Öl.
Das passt.
Das wird schon gut schmecken.
Ja, ich sehe das schon.
Und die gebe ich jetzt hier noch obendrauf.
Wobei, die kann man sich auch am Ende
so auf den Teller drauf machen.
Aber so ein paar gebe ich obendrauf.
Und wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr jetzt das Ganze noch
mit ein bisschen Käse überbacken.
Bisher wäre es jetzt so auch wirklich vegan.
Aber, wenn ihr sagt: "Komm, noch ein bisschen Würze",
dann gebt ruhig noch Käse drauf.
Und ich mache das jetzt.
Ich nehme jetzt hier den Tulum.
Das ist so ein Nomadenkäse, so ein richtig würziger,
aber nicht so schwer,
also echt gut.
Dann überbacke ich es noch mal kurz zwei Minuten
und dann wird es angerichtet.
Dann gibt es endlich Essen.
Und dann habt ihr ein komplettes Menü
aus dem Ofen
in einer Schale,
superlecker und vor allem sehr farbenfroh.
Und den Rest gebe ich auf die Teller.
[Musik]
So.
Jetzt kann schon probiert werden.
Murat, komm, komm, komm, komm!
Ich habe dich gerade gesehen!
Komm probieren!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ich war gerade auf der Baustelle.
Cool!
Nee, oder?
>> SALLY: Sag das doch nicht!
Ich habe euch ja auch gesagt, er mag keine Süßkartoffeln.
Aber, Schatz...
>> MURAT: Ich habe gedacht, das wäre ein Brot,
habe ich gedacht, und dann ist das Zeug drauf.
Aber das sind Süßkartoffeln.
>> SALLY: Ja, aber...
>> MURAT: Also es gibt
– ganz ehrlich, ich mag Süßkartoffeln, aber nur frittiert,
also richtig wie Pommes.
>> SALLY: Also als Pommes.
>> MURAT: Und ich mag sie eigentlich warm und...
>> SALLY: Also, was man wirklich machen muss, ist
diese Knoblauchzehen einfach rausdrücken.
Guckt mal.
So.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Man kann auch schon...
>> SALLY: Josh, komm, zeig mal in...
>> MURAT: Man kann auch schon eigentlich
das Rezept mit solchen Wörtern schon kaputt machen.
>> SALLY: Josh, guck mal. Komm, zeig mal in Nahaufnahme.
Einfach aus der Schale raus.
Zack!
Und hier so zack.
Und dann so drüberquetschen.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Das ist echt gut.
>> MURAT: Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, also
ja, rein vom Optischen her sieht es cool aus.
Aber vom Optischen sieht es natürlich aus wie Süßkartoffel.
>> SALLY: Kichererbsen habe ich geröstet.
>> MURAT: Kichererbsen sind gut. Das ist cool.
>> SALLY: Und ich finde
– ich sage dir jetzt mal, warum ich das Gericht cool finde.
Weil du hast eine Ofenform,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: hast dein komplettes Menü da drin.
Du hast die Süßkartoffel, die Gemüsebeilage,
hier noch ein bisschen Hülsenfrüchte.
>> MURAT: Ich finde, man muss auch ehrlich sein,
man kann nicht alles mögen. Wirklich nicht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Süßkartoffel gehört wirklich nicht
zu meinen Leibspeisen.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen Käse.
>> MURAT: Ich hoffe – ich weiß,
du könntest mich jetzt vielleicht überraschen.
Aber, wenn es nicht schmeckt,
ich sage dir ehrlich meine Meinung.
>> SALLY: Ach, komm, jetzt probier einfach. Mein Gott!
>> MURAT: Also, wenn du dich aufregst, wenn ich
meine Meinung sage, dann ist das nicht korrekt.
Okay?
>> SALLY: Doch, du darfst.
>> MURAT: Vielleicht mag ich es nicht. Dann hol doch
Sarah vielleicht noch.
>> SALLY: Ich probiere jetzt.
>> MURAT: Die mag das.
>> SALLY: Ja. Komm, probier.
>> MURAT: Ich sage es auch voll ehrlich,
also ich bin jetzt nicht voreingenommen.
>> SALLY: Und so ein bisschen...
Natürlich ist er voreingenommen.
>> MURAT: Nein, wirklich nicht.
Kann ich nicht einfach den Käse essen?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Der Käse ist lecker.
>> SALLY: Nein. Und so ein bisschen von diesem Spinatsaft
kommt dann auch so ein bisschen in die Süßkartoffel rein.
Und?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Voll lecker!
>> SALLY: Jetzt sag ehrlich.
>> MURAT: Nee, es ist cool.
Es ist cool.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Sarah!
>> MURAT: Nee, es ist gut.
>> SALLY: Trotzdem darf Sarah probieren.
>> MURAT: Hey, es ist...
Es ist jetzt...
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Sarah und ich, wir sind Gemüseliebhaber.
>> SARAH: Oh, wow!
Das sieht so schön bunt aus!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: Das mit dem Spinat mag ich.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
Weißt du, was jetzt richtig cool wäre?
Wenn du jetzt das nur mit dem Spinat gemacht hättest
und mit dem Ding,
richtig genial auf einem Stück Brot.
Hammer!
Wirklich!
>> SALLY: Ich weiß auch, warum er das mit dem Spinat mag.
Denn seine Mama...
>> MURAT: Meine Mutter macht das so.
>> SALLY: Das ist eigentlich...
>> MURAT: Was? Weißt du das noch?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Meine Mutter macht das.
>> SALLY: Bleib ruhig zwischen uns.
Bleib ruhig zwischen uns und seiner Mutter.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SARAH: Reden wir über deine Mutter?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Lasst meine Mutter aus dem Spiel,
lasse ich eure aus dem Keller.
>> SALLY: Und zwar haben wir hier diesen Spinat
und die Mama von ihm, die macht entweder Ei dazu
oder zum Beispiel Reis mit rein.
Und dann hat man wie so eine Art Risotto,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: aber so mit Spinat.
>> MURAT: Woah, Hammer!
>> SALLY: Nur nennen es die Türken nicht Risotto.
>> MURAT: Ja. Also ich will euch einen Tipp geben.
Also jetzt, wenn ihr jetzt Murat wärt,
>> SALLY: Ich finde es gut.
>> MURAT: was ihr nicht seid, aber sein könntet,
also rein hypothetisch gesehen,
>> SARAH: Ich mag die Kichererbsen.
>> MURAT: dann würde ich das genau so machen
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> MURAT: und dann einfach ein Brot toasten
und das voll cool als Brotbelag.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Ja, das ist auch...
>> MURAT: Wirklich richtig genial!
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, du würdest im Prinzip
nur die Süßkartoffeln ersetzen?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Man kann ja eine normale Kartoffel nehmen.
>> SARAH: Kichererbse?
>> MURAT: Auch richtig lecker, ganz ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ja, die sind lecker.
Die sind so knusprig.
>> SALLY: Und ist richtig gesund. Hm.
>> MURAT: Okay, die Süßkartoffel...
Es ist jetzt nicht so was, dass ich mich
nicht darüber freuen würde, aber...
Also es ist...
>> SALLY: Aber man kann ja für dich
eine normale Kartoffel nehmen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Ja, genau. Das wäre cool.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> MURAT: Eine normale Kartoffel. Genau.
>> SALLY: Aber die war optisch nicht so schön.
>> MURAT: Hey, hammercool!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> MURAT: Tut mir einen Gefallen.
>> SALLY: Ah, Samira! Komm!
>> MURAT: Macht das.
Macht das einfach mit einer normalen Kartoffel.
Richtig cool!
>> SALLY: Außer, wenn ihr Süßkartoffeln mögt,
dann macht es mit Süßkartoffeln.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Ich finde das Gericht so nämlich perfekt, wie es ist.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Habt ihr das selber jetzt gemacht?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm! Zeig mal, zeig mal, zeig mal!
Die Samira hat sich nämlich zum Zeugnis
eine Nähmaschine gewünscht
und jetzt näht sie seit Tagen.
Und jetzt haben sie sich vorhin mit der Greta Stoff gekauft.
Also
>> MURAT: Stoff gekauft.
>> SALLY: Stoff.
>> MURAT: Stoff. Mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Die Kinder sind neun.
Da darf man das so noch.
Und guckt einmal!
O Gott, sind die schön!
>> MURAT: Sieht man das?
Also nicht hier.
Zeigt mal, was ihr genäht habt.
>> SALLY: Oh, seid ihr süß! Mein Gott!
>> SAMIRA: Und das kann man auch als
>> SAMIRA & GRETA: Kleid
>> SAMIRA: für hierhin benutzen.
>> SALLY: Cool!
Könnt ihr auch so ein Kleid oder einen Rock
für Sarah und für mich machen?
Sarah, gelb?
>> SARAH: Ja, ich nehme gelb.
>> SAMIRA: Aber dann müsst ihr uns Geld oder Stoff...
>> SALLY: Und ich glaube, Ela will auch noch rosa.
>> SAMIRA: Ihr müsst uns dafür Geld oder Stoff geben.
>> GRETA: Wir haben schon für die Ela was genäht.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> SARAH: Wir geben euch Stoff.
>> SALLY: Wir geben euch Stoff.
>> MURAT: Ja, wir geben Stoff. Ja.
>> SALLY: Wenn eure Kinder mit neun sagen:
"Ich brauche Geld oder Stoff"...
>> MURAT: Kinder, die mit neun Jahren
schon eine Nähmaschine haben,
>> SALLY: Mega!
>> MURAT: finde ich eine richtig coole Geschichte.
>> SALLY: Ich komme gleich rüber, okay?
>> MURAT: Mit neun haben wir die Klamotten noch geklaut
und die machen sie selber.
>> SALLY: Sag so was nicht!
>> MURAT: Ich finde das wahnsinnig toll, wirklich!
>> SALLY: Das stimmt nicht, hat er wirklich nicht gemacht.
Also bei uns gibt es jetzt hier
>> MURAT: Wenn die wüsste...
>> SALLY: Süßkartoffeln mit Spinat.
Habt ihr da auch Lust drauf?
>> SAMIRA & GRETA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und dann das Rezept könnt ihr nachlesen in meiner App.
Und für den Murat gibt es nächstes Mal
einfach eine normale Kartoffel.
>> MURAT: Und sag mal ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Aber ich probiere es immer wieder.
>> MURAT: Seid voll ehrlich. Wie schmeckt es?
>> SAMIRA: Gut.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut.
>> SAMIRA: Nur, ich mag eben nicht so Süßkartoffeln,
aber die finde ich ganz gut.
>> MURAT: Siehst du?
>> SARAH: Was?
>> MURAT: Das ist mein Kind!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also...
>> MURAT: Ja, nimm eine Kartoffel. Wirklich!
Außer ihr mögt Süßkartoffeln.
>> SALLY: Und wir nehmen die Süßkartoffeln, gell, Sarah?
>> SARAH: Ja, wir nehmen alle.
>> SALLY: Und ich muss sagen, guckt mal...
>> SARAH: Wir können sie rausnehmen.
>> SALLY: Ich habe jetzt das große Blech und habe
– eins, zwei, drei –
vier Süßkartoffeln.
Was meinst du? Für wie viele Personen reicht das?
Schon so für vier bis sechs.
>> SARAH: Ja, eine Süßkartoffel
>> SALLY: Eine Süßkartoffel pro Person.
>> SARAH: pro Person ist gut.
>> SALLY: Ja, so vier Personen.
>> MURAT: Also mir reicht das drei Wochen.
>> SALLY: Tschau!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Übrigens sind normale Kartoffeln
>> SALLY: Cut!
>> MURAT: auch billiger.
>> MURAT: Die sind billiger. Die kosten nur ein Viertel.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Time-out!
Okay, wir gehen essen.
Tschau!
>> SAMIRA: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
>> GRETA: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Geht ihr mal Stoff kaufen
mit der Mutter.
>> SALLY: Los!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aua!
Ist noch warm.
Ich hole es gleich.
>> MURAT: Echt cool eigentlich. Echt!
Schmeckt super. Wirklich!
[Musik]